الأدميرال هو الوقت المناسب لجانب فلاديمير بوتين ،
ولا أعتقد ذلك مايكل وأنت تعلم أننا
يجب أن نبدأ بالقول إن بوتين
كان سيد سوء التقدير منذ أن
بدأ هذا الشيء ،
لقد استخف بفيلودمير زيلينسكي ، لقد
اعتقد أنه كان ممثلًا كوميديًا سابقًا
اتضح أن الرجال يحبون  ونستون
تشرشل استخف بالروح القتالية
للشعب الأوكراني ، وأخبر بوتين
قواته أنه سيتم الترحيب بك بزجاجات من
الفودكا عندما تغزو جيدًا ، حيث تم
الترحيب بهم بزجاجات من السوائل القابلة للاشتعال
تسمى زجاجات مولوتوف ،
لقد استخف بإرادة
وقدرة الغرب على ذلك.  تماسكوا معًا
ووضعوا عقوبات جدية جدًا
عليه ، لذا النقطة واحد
بوتين هو الخطأ في الحساب هنا
والنقطة الثانية هي قبل أن
أه نقرر أن بوتين
ينجح حقًا هنا ، دعنا نضع ذلك في
نصابه وأنت تعرف أن هذا مايكل
كان هدفه هو التغلب على
البلد بأكمله ليأخذ مائة بالمائة منه
، فقد حصل على خمسة بالمائة إضافية ،
أي أنه كان يتحكم
في 15 من ر  قبل أن يبدأ هذا الشيء ،
إنه الآن يسيطر على حوالي 20 في
المائة ، أود أن أقول إنه حتى منحه
فائدة الشك في أنه
يسيطر الآن على 20 من البلاد
بهدف مائة في المائة وهي
درجة فاشلة بعد أن قال كل ذلك  بالتأكيد
يجب أن نقلق بشأن إرادة
وقدرة الغرب على البقاء معًا
بمرور الوقت
، وقد يقول البعض ، انظر إلى
أفغانستان ، لقد قمنا بطي بطاقاتنا التي
علقناها هناك لمدة 20 عامًا ، وبالمناسبة
لم ننسحب في العالم  الحرب الأولى التي
لم ننسحب في الحرب العالمية الثانية ، لم ننسحب
في
كولومبيا ، لم ننسحب في البلقان ،
لن أراهن على الغرب متماسكًا ،
لذا لا أعتقد أن
الوقت قد حان لفلاديمير بوتين  جانب